hi my name's thor um 22 years old how
many thousands of hours of bloopers do
we think there is from the mcu some epic
moments look totally goofy while other
scenes we were lucky to get at all
considering just how many takes it took
to do without laughing
ready to giggle and perfection
number one with this duo on set nailing
a scene took a lot longer than usual i
saw you from across the room
and
my
heart just exploded jake and tom pretty
much had an endless bromance on the set
finding ways to make their time together
even more special that's when we team up
and we sort of become best buds
on and off screen just because they're
pals doesn't mean they were easy on each
other as co-stars though
spoilers
and defense could still be taken no
matter how hard they tried to contain
their laughter it was rumbling beneath
the scene just like hydroman ripping
through the canals of venice but no
matter what their work grind never
stopped
number two is it a movie set or a dance
party the lines are blurred black
panther might just be home to some of
the best marvel dance parties there ever
were they danced and danced and danced
waiting to shoot why not get some shimmy
action in keep that energy fierce oh and
there was a whole lot of freestyle
rapping you just got the skills that's
just killing them
they know how to make a set a party
number three the big kid is a big
director
and thank goodness they did because it
only added to the fun of the film what's
great about taika is his humor what does
he have to say about it what the world
needs right now is korg the rock man
we couldn't agree more taika running
around in his korg mocap getup is really
a sight to see a motion capture suit
what is that pajamas with triangles all
over them still he maintained authority
even while looking absurd it's very hard
to be taken seriously as a director when
you're wearing that stuff since taika
was in the cast as well as directing
apparently any role could be up for
grabs you just got replaced but hey what
do you expect there's no continuity when
you're living in the moment his
performances well the bts speaks for
itself yeah i'm just trying to get
through oh scrapper 142 the 140 tooth
scrapper how many takes did it take to
get just right daddy's just a big kid oh
and when all else fails dance it out
that is how you make movies
number four the fighting on screen is
intense but behind the scenes it could
uh well see for yourself no
oh
i'm sorry
simulu was calm cool and collected
showing off his moves but without all
the added visual effects and music the
action doesn't quite hit the same way
what that's a that's a bow drop right
there i'm gonna put it down nicely
because it's ancient aquafina somehow
wound up scaring herself at times oh and
special shout out to huang for this
elfish portal jump
number five you'd think these two were
actually related scarlett johansson and
florence pew weren't quiet about how
much they adored each other johansson
feeling like pew was just full of life
they picked on and fall with each other
like young siblings half the time they
were filming i can't move over move i
can't there's a camera there i'm so
sorry don't open your eyes simple tasks
could become a whole lot harder i don't
know where this could be
they had lots of fun but there's no
question they still hit their mark when
it counted
every time
the drinking problem
[Music]
number six
being a full-time superhero is tough
work they don't always stick the landing
literally it takes a whole lot of time
it outtakes to get those moments just
right we need to destroy thank you
who are you guys
tom holland hadn't totally nailed all
his spidey moves by infinity war and
while most of the time these pros kept
their cool sometimes they were pushed a
bit too far how long do i start here
over acting for
number seven
no it's not some abstract holiday just
the reality of filming in a city full of
birds they nev that was not in the
script zendaya had all sorts of cool
experiences shooting far from home
including traveling around the world and
of course meeting the local wildlife
seeds times pigeons times me equals a
disaster these were definitely some
workplace hazards no one thought to warn
the actress about and john the director
was like yes we're gonna put some seeds
on you and just let the pigeons go for
it luckily nose and dales were harmed in
the making of this film i'll never
forget that moment i've gotten over my
fear of pigeons since then
number eight
she's regalas can be on screen but on
set it wasn't always so smooth this is
going really well even in this silly
looking mocap suit cape landscape could
get a bit too feisty
freestyle now while the actress nails
her performance it didn't come as easily
as you might expect on the day despite a
ton of prep
sorry guys
i've been training for months oh and
there was also that time that hila took
a tumble not so powerful now do i should
make the noises in my mouth today
number nine
these superheroes weren't always so
smooth sure she can wield chaos magic
but walking well it's not always a sure
bet we always saw thor looking like well
the god of thunder but fat thor was a
whole new deal and his usual grace and
balance well we've never seen a thor
like this before he has such dexterity
as a talent rdj isn't always slick as he
seems in the avengers movies
i broke it and of course captain marvel
herself brie larson knew how to trust
the process on this one because well
yeah does it look cool or
it doesn't feel cool but if it looks
cool that's what matters
number 10
salma hayek is new to the mcu so some of
the practicalities of existing in the
world were a bit lost on the actress
it's my first time talking to a
celestial i don't know angelina jolie
might be a superhero but still retains a
human level of clumsiness
what's your superpower
those long days on set could also make
it tricky to remember exactly how to say
names words you name it so why didn't
you guys help fight thanos
wouldn't you guys help fight thanos no
but at the end of the day like all good
superheroes they knew how to dance it
out
number 11 line malfunction prop
malfunction landing pose malfunction
we've got them all
[Music]
you know that feeling when your shield
just won't do what it's supposed to or
your helmet for that matter try that
again
it's stuck
chris evans and kobe smulders were
living the struggle filming the winter
soldier
flubs on set weren't really everyone's
cup of tea though we're looking at you
jackson
i got confused with my eyeliner i think
i looked directly into camera i don't
care you just forgot the line
number 12
time traveling is enough to throw anyone
for a loop the marvel team let katherine
han go wild on the wanda vision set
making for some very real chaos magic
han went for it and poor sparky suffered
the throwback and time seemed to make
elizabeth olsen and paul bettany feel a
little kooky what a gas
i'm very funny do you want to talk about
your butt yeah i did want to talk about
my butt according to them it was all in
the clothing it makes me have better
posture and i makes me want to do walk
like this we have to admit we dig the
wiggle walks makes me stand properly and
it makes me kind of want to do this too
and then of course there was the whole
performing in front of a live studio
audience bit and then i changed
number 13 filming guardians of the
galaxy on earth made for some very
strange looking moments on set how weird
does this blue on blue look poor chris
pratt was stuck battling on his own even
the most intense action fell short it
looks more like gamora's stuck in a web
in total silence
[Music]
speaking of silence palm clement tf in
this moment is mantis in the subtle
breeze yeah it's a bit less epic
number 14 take after take after take you
know how it goes scarjo was fumbling
with her weapons and other superheroes
were missing their landings completely
hey can i ask you a question in my suit
is it too much with his entire face
covered we'd say yeah it's probably a
bit too much tom you do it for me
[Music]
the execution of this punch
top marks the aftermath
yeah it could use a bit of work oh
superhero tip try to get the best rap
gifts
hey nate do we own these shipping
containers i'd love one for a rap gift
number 15
we can't not talk about it we're living
the dream i'm living the dream you may
not be alligator loki is ferocious on
screen but behind the scenes well the
abstract life-sized blue stuffedy it
looks well a lot less fierce it's a bird
it's a plane it's a flying alligator
loki this loki got the royal treatment
casually hanging around in crew members
arms while they weren't working
hello okay anyone else's abs hurting
right now
find out what the ghost wants
let's get this ghost how they get any
work done we'll never know more
stop eating so much
which scene do you think looked most fun
to film
[Music]